Hey,
what's going on is bill burn is time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Dan.
Yeah.
Just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on your,
hello.
This is Susan Blues teen calling.
Um,
what's a character is to,
is to call up a buddy of mine all the time.
We pretend to be his casting director and I would just call them up with the
worst fucking auditions.
Every,
hello,
this is Susan Bloomstein called link.
I haven't no audition for you with for a feature.
Do you have a problem with being naked around other men in positions that
involves,
she's staring at your ankles.
If you have a prop,
if not,
give me a cool stupid shit like that.
It was always like,
you know,
something that I guess would be considered homophobic as instead of just being
funny,
you know,
is it a homophobic to suggest that he would be uncomfortable staring at his
ankle ankle,
so I should say,
and the company of other men,
I don't know what's going on.
How was your Thursday?
Did she get paid today?
Huh?
Did they write some numbers on a piece of paper and then you stuck it in a
machine and somehow you can get waffles.
It's in the air,
man.
All the money's in the air now.
I don't know where it is,
you know,
safe to say either.
Some white dude has all of it.
Russian dude,
which has guests.
It is a white tube,
but white dude means American dude,
right?
Or English,
right.
Russian dude or Chinese dude.
One of them's got it.
Maybe somebody in Singapore has all the money with Japanese guy.
Then of course you've got the fucking Saudi princes.
They got something like six people have it all right now.
And the rest of us just get pieces of paper with numbers on it.
But as long as we believe in it,
no matter what they say on TV,
no matter how bad they say it's getting,
as long as we just continue to fucking believe in it,
just keep writing numbers to each other.
Right.
Next thing you know,
I got a shirt.
You got a Taco?
Everybody's happy.
Susan Blumenstein Corley.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
so here's what's going on with me.
Last night.
Me and the lovely Nia,
my beautiful,
we went down and saw a Iggy pop.
He has a new album out the postpartum depression and um,
basically like 90% of Queens of the stone age was backing him up.
John Theater was not on drums,
um,
but it was pretty much,
I think the rest of the band and Iggy pop came out.
It was fucking amazing show.
I'd lucked into these tickets.
I was doing a comedy show.
I ran into somebody that works for the band.
They said,
we've got an a couple of extra to tickets.
Do you want to go?
My freckles stood up at attention and of course I went,
I went down there and God damn it,
what an amazing show.
Silverman opened up.
She fucking crushed it and hey,
the pot man,
there's a bucket list,
right?
Their bucket list one to go see the guy fucking comes out there,
He's got on a sports coat with no shirt underneath of the 68 years old.
All right.
After one song,
the code is gone and he's prancing around with no shirt on.
68 years old.
With some fucking shit guy just doesn't give a fuck.
I'm going to fuck,
I'm going to post a picture of the guy.
You know what I mean?
He's still in great shape,
you know?
Sure.
There's a little,
uh,
less density issues here or there with the skin,
but I mean,
other than that,
the guy looks like he can do more pushups than I could ever do.
I hope I look that good at his age.
You know,
when he stills got that beautiful Marsha Brady fucking haircut.
Gorgeous hair.
Oh God.
I was jealous.
Um,
anyways,
the band absolutely fucking smashed it.
He was all over the stage.
Um,
it was,
it was fucking incredible,
man.
It was just a,
just an absolutely amazing night.
And then me and Nia finished it off as much as I'm trying to get in shape.
One of the great things to do out here in Los Angeles has to hit your favorite
fucking Taco truck.
Oh,
late night taco spot.
Um,
it's just the best.
And there was one,
uh,
I got a buddy of mine could another comedian for Shaw who's like a connoisseur
of all the taco trucks.
I was basically like,
I,
I went down just east of the fucking one west of the one 10,
um,
you know,
and like Beverly Boulevard,
what do you got?
And He fucking,
he gave me like three taco trucks,
like Google mapped all the way back to my house and we ended up stopping off at
one and a,
Oh fuck.
I didn't get any Tacos,
actually got a Goddamn case of Dia,
which is the classic default White Guy Order at a taco truck.
You know,
can I get a check in case?
Can I get one of them?
I'll be technically,
he was sad.
Even Mexican.
It's just,
chase would check in,
hey,
are we do that?
It was just a,
a,
a great night.
And um,
another night where I didn't smoke a cigar.
I haven't smoked a cigar since February 16th.
And,
uh,
you know,
you have a problem with something when you know the exact date,
you know of,
uh,
when you stopped doing it,
you know other shit.
If you just don't give a fuck,
he just like,
you want to go to Mcdonald's?
Yeah,
no.
Was the last time you ate there?
Oh,
I don't know man.
I spent a while we'll get a year.
That's when you don't have a process.
That's,
that's when,
if there was an issue of addiction,
it's just completely out of your fucking life.
But I know the exact date was February 16th.
I know where I was.
I know what I smoked and I know what I felt like when I had it and I've been
thinking about it every fucking day.
And um,
I'm trying to go on a little bit of a run here because if a,
if I don't cut the shit out of my life this summer,
I will be a four year smoker.
Like what the fuck?
What am I doing?
Um,
so,
but I've been holding fast with these uh,
fast are holding strong,
whatever the fucking expression is.
I only have two a month.
Alright.
I two in January,
two and a half in February because I started smoking when it wasn't lit well,
and I've got another one so I had one and a half that nice.
That's not bad.
Right?
Come on.
You guys aren't doctors generally speaking?
I should be.
All right.
My body can handle that two and a half fucking days.
I mean two and a half,
two a month.
Once every 14 days and it's still fucking stupid.
Maybe I'll just go down to one a month.
I want to be special occasion guy.
I figured I'll smoke one at the rose bowl smoke once,
Superbowl Sunday,
my birthday.
Uh,
we don't,
she got flagged day then.
I don't give a fuck about that.
Okay.
It's bunch of Jewish holidays in
September.
I am in show business as a nod to them.
That'd be really selfish.
Like I give a shit,
right?
Like I give a shit about,
you know,
like I'm actually acknowledging another religions.
The real reasons I not just looking for an excuse to smoke a cigar
tall,
my Jewish brothers and sisters out there and the sign of support.
What are you going to deal bill?
Ah,
make a donation to the museum of tolerance?
No,
I am going to smoke a Cuban cigar and honored to all of your wonderful
contributions to comedy and Shell business.
Um,
okay.
Like for a year,
that would be perfect.
Right?
There's not a fucking doctor on the planet.
They always got a day.
Always get there.
Their job is just a rain on your parade.
I saw if I went in and say,
doc,
look,
I smoked for a year.
Is that bad?
And be it,
you know why?
You know it's,
you know,
it's not bad,
but they always go.
Ideally.
Yeah.
Ideally I'd live in a fucking bubble and I would be breathed perfect fucking air
and drink clean water and I have um,
a microbiome.
What the fuck are you doing doc?
You gotta be doing something
going in here,
taking everybody's blood pressure.
All God Damn Day looking at fucking skin tags should telling me you don't have
an outlet.
MMM.
I don't know.
So anyways,
having said all of that,
probably smoke what next week,
but I liked this month,
this month is going good because um,
you know,
I've already like,
the first two months of the year I really feel like I shook my hand should be
shaking as I'm talking about this as sub Adam on a smoke.
I uh,
I had my first one January 1st and then January 8th I had the second one.
I was like,
fuck,
the month isn't even half over and I got a white knuckle it the rest of the way
and then I did it again in February.
I smoke more on like the fifth and then one on like this I guess the 16th then I
got another two fucking weeks.
So now I feel like I'm ahead of the game cause it's like the 10th.
If I can just make it to like the 50th,
you know,
then I can actually go on a run and do one every week for four weeks.
Then white knuckle it to April.
Uh,
just sucks.
How come everything fun fucking kills you.
You know,
just fucking kills you sitting around Eating Goddamn yogurt by the way.
I figured out what was causing the train,
not the lead,
the fucking station.
I became all Billy Parfait,
right?
And I went down to this shoe shop and they will fucking raving about this.
You know,
this all natural yogurt with coconut in it.
all that probiotic has probiotics in it.
This is,
you know,
this isn't negative by,
this is positive pro.
This is proactive.
You have two kinds of bacteria within your intestinal track.
Shut the fuck up.
I put this stuff in them.
I couldn't,
I couldn't ship the days.
I just kept beating it cause they're that doubted the juice shack there.
Right.
They kept telling me how healthy it was and a little did it.
Little did I know I was building like a fucking wall.
You know what's said city there in Greece with all,
it's the whole city is just a bunch of white walls,
you know?
That's what I was building in my stomach.
Where you built?
I don't know.
It's the first thing I thought of.
Hey,
go fuck yourself.
You know,
I'd like to see you not shit for three days and try to dance around it and keep
it funny.
Okay.
How did they get this mood?
Um,
anyways,
hold on one second.
Hold on.
Nancy Reagan died.
Everybody.
Yeah,
she died and a lot of people were really upset about that.
You know,
she was a great woman.
I'll tell you what made her great.
Now the shape she kept herself in,
considering her husband had jelly beans all over the fucking place.
The fact that she could just say no to those goddamn things,
right.
She's walking around.
There's something about being that skinny though.
After a while though,
it's just like you live for fucking ever,
but you just get like a bird person.
You know?
Like if she was my,
uh,
grandmother,
I would have built like a giant birdcage said that hung from the ceiling and
he's just me.
I'd make it go in there and purchase on it.
You know,
I'm not opening the door unless you tell me.
I'm still in the,
well Nancy or I guess I would say grandma Reagan's Greg and um,
all right.
This is why there's this whole podcast is gone off the fucking rails so too,
God damn distracted him talking about putting dead first ladies and birdcages.
That's not right is it?
He's such a weird fella that Reagan,
some people you talk to,
he single handedly defeated the Russians.
The reality is did he come off the fucking bench and he did.
He hit the last three.
You know the dagger.
He put the game away.
I would say,
you know,
by tricking them into thinking that we were actually going to have shit up and
out of space to stop this shit from coming over here.
You know,
that's the weird
thing about trying to bomb somebody from the other side of the fucking world.
If you're too lazy to fly over,
you got to start.
You got to shoot them.
Remember Robert Parish,
his foul shot and you know it was a rainbow.
That's how you got to do it.
You actually got to send it in because of the curvature of the earth.
You got to send it fucking up and over.
You know what I mean?
It's like when you,
you're sitting on the couch and you got a Napkin and you want to throw it into a
barrel,
but you'll fucking office chair.
It's right there.
You,
you got to go up and over.
You know they do that with missiles.
Somebody actually figured that out sometimes.
Some superstar
fucking intelligent scientist guy.
Right.
As opposed to the really dumb ones that they put in the nuclear programs.
Bill,
this guy had just sit there
and like figure that out,
you know,
out of our airspace into the troposphere up into the stratosphere over the fuck.
It goes right out to outer space.
Reedus the atmosphere without blowing up right on the White House.
Nothing but precedent.
Right.
They just sitting there talking,
shit,
what a fucking job.
You know,
and there's some other psycho,
you know,
they got cameras in space or some shit or somebody flying around with that
direct TV satellite on the back of his plane just falling around.
Brezhnev,
Gorbachev,
trying to figure out where they're at.
Okay.
So they always have the exact coordinates.
That's what it,
that's the level of stress like Obama has and all these guys.
That's why they age like 90 years.
Cause they know the other team,
right?
They go and Billy Bella check on them.
You know,
they got cameras on your end,
on the top of your fucking head,
wherever you go.
You know,
I'd be all paranoid,
be doing fucking head fakes as I was walking down the hall to the Oval Office.
All right.
I won't even go in the Oval Office saying I'm not going in there.
I would have,
I'd have a double,
I'd always be down in the basement,
you know.
Then years later after I died,
you know,
all my staff would start fucking coming out talking shit about me.
He's very fearful,
man,
for all the bravado.
During his speeches,
he spent the entire eight years of his presidency in the,
the,
well,
we're not allowed to say how far down it goes,
but let's just say there's one hell of a basement under that house.
Um,
okay.
Even think he fucking lives there.
There's no fucking way he lives there.
He just lives there.
You ever seen the White House?
It's just right there.
You know
he doesn't live there.
I bet there's a fucking,
you take an elevator.
That's just like a,
then when Steve jobs used to make those fucking speeches at those nerd fest,
right?
They go down there,
you know,
he'd come out and he's fucking Jane's and no belt,
and he just,
I look at that
and all the nerds are like,
oh my God.
I think that's what,
and then he just fucking leave.
Nobody knew where he lived.
Bye.
Why?
Why is Bill Gates have a more reclusive fucking house?
Is The house reclusive bill?
Does it?
Does the House make the choice
to be introverted?
Whatever he has,
he has a fucking house.
No one could get to.
I can't get anywhere fucking near Bill Gates' house.
Right.
Okay.
But the White House,
you can walk right up to the gate.
Oh,
right.
You can come right up to it.
It's just going to put me on a list.
MMM.
I bet.
What's his face?
I Bet Bill Gates has got a fucking Goddamn,
you know,
you remember that stead star wars thing that Reagan wanted to put up for
fucking,
you know the Robert Parish nuclear warhead rainbow shot from the Kremlin,
right?
I bet he's got those full like drones.
I bet he hates drugs.
He's all pissed off.
How dare you assigned my technology.
Okay.
I think he's an evil mother fucker and that's why it gives away all that money.
You know what I mean?
It's weird.
He's like,
he's like the sociopath with a heart of gold.
He's kind of like Dexter.
Right?
But if he was like getting the laptops rather than just cutting up people,
but it's only the bad people.
I was never able to get past that.
Look at you.
God Damn.
You look good.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
What do you mean really?
Because they got to hitch my wagon to a dog.
Fucking totally superficial.
All right,
you look hot and you better keep looking hard.
Cause I'll tell you right now,
I'll go right down to the used car lot and I'll start shopping.
Okay,
I'll trade gin.
I'm not going to trade you in and about.
I Dunno.
You're a classic though.
You one of those,
those ones that's going to last for awhile.
You know,
I'm a treat you well changing the fluids every 3000 miles out is gross.
Disgusting.
Um,
well thank you for saying that.
I think,
I feel like I went out to a show last night and had some drinks and aids and
late night tacos.
Yeah,
she did.
It was so much fun as you talk about the shame.
Yeah.
How about Eggy?
The confidence of Vicki pop going out this 68 has more swag than all of you
bitches.
Why are you checking the listeners?
I don't know.
I guess it's funny cause you're hung over and you don't,
yeah.
I don't mean do it tight the listeners,
I'm just saying.
Yeah.
The swag he had out there was the whole band and ag of course is legendary.
That was a great show.
I'm really glad I went.
You know,
I wasn't feeling up to it,
but I'm glad I a great name for an album to,
huh?
Post the post pop did.
I'll post pop depression.
Yeah.
Very good.
It was awesome.
And the band was all wearing custom YSL for those of you who are in is designer
clothing YSL is he a Saint Laurent?
He Santa overall ease in Laurel.
Yeah.
So they were all wearing custom YSL.
Even the roadies,
like the crew was wearing like,
like trousers and ties from Ysl,
which is pretty dope.
Like Josh Look Great.
And that suit Denny,
whenever you say trousers,
I think of that Classic Classic Louis C k joke when he used to talk about
whenever he does.
Yeah.
When a three would call phone sexy though.
He's get that 70 year old woman.
I'm taking off your trousers.
I think we need to bring cleos water dish in here.
Yeah.
Cause she's laying in the sun.
Why don't you go do that cause or grab another mic if you're going to be on
this.
No,
I'm not.
I just came in say hi,
I'm Jesus.
You have to go to the gym.
That was one of my favorite dumb jokes of all time.
What is it?
Gay Horsey.
Hey,
I'm sorry.
Come on.
You got to admit that's funny on some level.
Um,
all right.
So anyways,
what was I talking about?
Oh,
I was talking about Bill Gates.
Swat a away the fucking droughts and having more security then a old town there.
Motown in the fucking Meson blog.
Yeah,
Polaroid of the sun.
She's done one hike and she's done.
It's already fucking hot out.
He had global warming Nini.
You're looking fucking good.
All right.
Beat it.
Ah,
go to the gym.
Keep it looking good.
That's part of your contract.
Show me shut up.
Um,
all right.
I fucking hate this whole password thing.
You know,
for the,
I figured out what the fuck was wrong with my eye,
my iTunes,
which is basically,
I can't listen to anything that I've downloaded on my fucking laptop because I
have too many other devices that have already been accepted by Itunes,
so I have to deactivate some other shit.
Um,
I finally figured that out.
I didn't figure it out.
I just went on,
I went on the Internet.
They basically typed in,
uh,
please give me the answer.
I went there looking,
you'd go right back to the sun.
Cleo.
She fucking loves the Sun.
Um,
all right,
what else did I want to talk about?
All the garage gym is becoming a reality.
Hey,
speak calming
reality.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
no thanks to fucking rogue fitness.
Jesus Christ.
What an arrogant God damn company that is.
I specifically asked that company as a celebrity in my mind to send me a bunch
of free shit for my garage so that I could then hype their company to my 40
listeners.
And can you believe this?
I hope you're sitting down.
Can you believe they never got back to me?
All right.
Well,
because I'm fucking immature.
I got to go vengeance.
Now I have to add my vengeance on that company.
This is what I'm gonna do.
I am going to buy all of the shit from them.
That's what I'm going to do.
And then you know what?
When they call me and say,
hey,
thanks for using it,
I'm not going to take that phone call.
All that getting out of me is the price they want for their fucking goods.
Right?
Does that make any sense?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I just throw it out there.
They never get back to me.
I was half serious.
I don't like that.
I don't like people giving me free shit cause then they fucking own you on some
level anyways.
You know.
Hey,
you know,
remember that time I gave you a chin up bar?
I mean what the fuck?
All right,
I'll give you a ride to the airport.
Fuck you know,
you just,
you can't get out of it.
You can't get out of it.
So anyways,
I am going to fucking do this thing up.
This is,
this is,
this is the game plan.
I'm getting that rogue fitness thing that collapse it.
You can fold back into the wall.
I'm getting a workout bench.
You know,
I'm so excited for that because I'm so sick of going to the fucking gym and
there's always some,
there's always somebody on it.
If somebody is always benching right.
And uh,
I can also do squats and I'll be able to do pull ups and then I got my atomic
holds and I'm going to put those above where my truck is.
I'll just have to pull my truck out,
which I know kind of sucks,
but who gives a fuck?
I'm going to have an epoxy floor put in,
right?
And then Nia wants an adjustable speed bag over in the corner,
which is great because all I'll have to do is adjust it like twice.
And just like the bicycle I bought her,
she's never going to use it again.
Then I can just lock that fucker into position.
Right.
We'll get it did they did a boarded up.
He did a pub,
right?
You've got to put it in the corner.
I'm worried about the noise,
you know,
banging on,
blowing out my ear drums.
Forget about that.
Annoying the shit out of my neighbors because everybody out here lives on top of
one another.
So um,
I figure if I do that and then I'm have those interlocking rubber things
underneath all the gym area,
I'll have a place where I could skip rope.
Right.
I can do my pull ups.
My only thing is I'm getting rid of my pull up and dip station thing that I have
and I'll be able to do the pull up still,
but I won't be able to do dips.
So if anybody knows of an attachment that works.
I was thinking of just having the handle's coming out of the wall.
If they make something like that,
which would look really weird for some reason.
What are,
what is those that fucking Porto glory holes.
It's like the glory hole of fucking,
it's like the glory hole of workout equipment to just have like the dip fucking
things just coming out of the wall,
right?
No.
What am I going to perverted mine?
What the fuck do you want from me?
Uh,
how long into this fucking thing are we?
23 minutes.
Michael Jordan.
All right,
here we go.
Here we go.
Let's,
uh,
let's read a little bit of advertising.
All right.
Oh fuck.
I didn't talk about self driving cars.
I got the biggest argument with fucking forest shot today.
Oh,
we,
we will go and we never get an argument.
We would just fucking eat it.
He's like a scientist and I'm a dope,
so that's just fucking right there.
That's just a recipe for it to go off the rails.
I brought up for us shit before and if you're um,
okay.
Um,
I think he said he's going to be in Nashville soon.
I'm sure he has a website.
He uh,
he actually,
he opens for Jim Jefferies all the time.
Um,
he's fucking hilarious.
Like I would go hiking with somebody who wasn't funny.
You know what I mean?
It's bad enough when you got to work with the comic that isn't that funny.
But if you're going to walk next to him for like an hour and a half who,
I'll tell you that's a rough one.
You know.
All right.
Tracker or track are smart cars,
smart phones,
smart,
Hobbs Technology has made everything smart.
Okay.
I'm smack Joe,
you know.
Okay.
No,
I like everybody says Fredo all right,
but losing your stuff still makes Matt fee.
People feel fucking stupid.
Tracker
makes losing things a thing of the past tracker is a coin size device that
locates Ms. Plays,
keys,
wallets,
bags,
computers,
anything in seconds.
Just paired tracker to your smartphone.
Attach it to anything.
Put it on your deck.
Where are my balls?
Right next to mine.
Yay.
Thank you.
Tracker.
Um,
you can fight.
You get it.
You get what the fuck it is?
Lose your phone.
Press a button.
Can't find your nuts.
There they are,
uh,
with over 1.5.
I will they over explained that thick.
It's like I get,
I got it.
The first two sentences with over 1.5 million devices tracker has the largest
crowd gps network in the world.
So your last item shows up on a map.
Even if it's miles away,
never lose anything.
Again with tracker,
just think if tracker was on everything,
no one would steal anything anymore.
Yes they would.
They figured out how to go around.
Whatever listeners to this show,
get a special discount of 40% off your first tracker device.
Go to the tracker.com.
Go to the tracker.com and enter Promo Code burpee.
You are are the hardest thing you'll ever have to find is their website.
Oh yeah.
What about love?
Can you put this on?
They're going to do that and that stupid dating site with that stupid piano blue
to the Doodoo and that Chicco.
Ooh,
the fucking bitch.
The one who makes me as
sandwich.
Yeah,
it's the longer version.
They never show that one.
All right,
got a tracker.com right now and at the Promo Code [inaudible] for 40% off.
Again,
that's tracker.com Promo Code Bar.
Why use your,
when you got technology,
self-driving fucking cars.
Self driving cars are so fucking stupid.
One of the great things about cars is he might have people that they kill every
year,
which is great for the environment and then you can have these fucking robots
and it was real.
It's going to be great.
I could stare at my smart phone as I drive to work.
Give you think all these fucking now what are these robots do?
You know?
Just decide one day that they're sick of being the Goddamn Limo driver and
driving us around and they kind of share a look,
you know,
had a red light and that starts a revolution just like in the Ukraine where it
just took a couple of jerk offs on Facebook and next thing you know Putin is
gone.
You know what?
Maybe we need to Robert Parish a little closer.
Do a little fucking layup.
Alright,
trunk club everybody.
If you're anything like me honey,
then you know exactly what you like and how it is nap to the 12 down to this six
bitches,
except when you're in the wine aisle.
I thought that just said tranny surprise because I was doing that fucking hacky
gay accent Tannins and terrors me nothing to you.
It means nothing to me.
I don't even know what they are.
The types of wine,
I'm guessing unless she happened to be a fancy pants,
professional sommeliers.
I hate when people just make somebody like your fancy pants because you
understand something that takes a little bit of brains.
I respect anybody then understands wine.
I like those people.
They look at it,
they swirl it around.
They shoved their fucking honker in there,
you know,
put it their mouth.
They let it swirl around at the different flavors.
Hit him,
you know,
tasting the barrel,
tasting history and let it go down there.
SOFIC is it hit stick?
Good.
Okay.
They live across it.
That woman,
half their age,
they pointed something flashy and they slipped a roofie in her drink.
Right.
It finished uploading commercial.
Sorry.
All right.
Okay.
Where am I?
Here.
Okay.
Please include all the falling points during your read.
I'll do as many as I can.
How about that?
Well,
with club Debbie clubbed your self driving cars.
Sit for me.
I'm special.
The guessing game is over club.
Debbie,
don't fall.
Don't fall for JB already bought it for me and it's enough bushes.
It's the world's only personalized wine club and your wines are sent directly to
your door.
Not only just club Debbie Clip Debbie and wish don,
which Tony Romm show.
Which d Roth.
That's why I come give everyone nicknames.
Send you wine.
They send you wine that you will love drinking.
That's because club Daddy,
I can speak Spanish.
Easy.
Six question quiz figures out your pallets.
Uh,
so that,
so that every body,
that bottle you get your fucking like Jesus Christ club.
Debbie,
I got a ranch is re is leading the grape to glass wine revolution.
They worked directly with the vignettes to cut out the middlemen,
which saves you money.
Oh yeah,
you're going to pay those immigrant workers any more money.
Then you're going to send some of that savings their way.
Maybe they can get a new fucking hat club.
Debbie,
buying a plane on an aquifer even offers you a no risk guarantee that you will
love what they send you or your money back.
And right now club w and a weapons of mass destruction is offering my listeners
50% off your first order.
And when you go to club,
Debbie,
I'm a war president club [inaudible] dot com slash burr wine.
A wine should be fun.
Not Pretentious.
Why?
Why does it have to take all the fucking class?
So I think it should be a classy goddamn thing and I think he should take the
time to learn about it.
If you want to get into it,
rather be,
go fucking figure it all out for me.
Why don't you use club Debbie?
I was safe during my watch,
right?
The why can't you use this thing to educate yourself?
Why does it have to all be about taking your hands off the fucking wheel and
letting some robot pick it out for you?
My tree stump.
Why don't you be fun?
Not Pretentious.
Evidently start learning as you drink.
I guess they're saying learning as he started drinking club had a com slash.
Burr.
You'll even get 50% off your first order.
Think about that.
Turn your teeth gray for 50% off.
That's club debbie.com/ [inaudible] all right,
one more.
Can you guys sit through this one more fucking reading here.
Legal Zoom.
To run a successful business,
you need to make the most of your time and money.
Good dues.
Legals of can help you save both during national small business month.
Fuck that up,
but I have the right voice,
right?
Legal Zoom is the smart way to start your business right now and you incorporate
or form an LLC.
You could also save money on some of the basics to get up and running.
That didn't seem like that made sense to me.
Like a three month trial on quickbooks online accounting software and a domain
name for a year through web.com both at no chach after your business is set up,
legal zoom can can help with a lot more reviewing content contracts and dealing
with day to day legal hurdles takes time away from growing your business.
That's what legal zooms business legal plan is for.
You get legal advice for your business from independent attorneys licensed in 48
states.
Oh the lower 48 or are you including Alaska and Hawaii and maybe not Wyoming in
Michigan?
Who knows?
You can also get access to Ndas,
lease agreements and more.
The best part is you won't get charged by the hour.
Since legalzoom isn't a law firm,
instead you pay for low a low monthly fee or fee.
Jesus Christ.
How long is this?
Save Time and money starting and running your business during national small
business month@legalzoom.com today.
Don't forget to enter Burt in the referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com,
legalzoom.com.
All right.
There you go.
Hey,
did anybody see that fucking hilarious.
Twitter back and forth between Kanye West in a dead mile,
a dead mouse.
However the fuck you say his name,
I guess card.
You took a screenshot and then the fucking screenshot,
allegedly there was something up there that showed some website where he was
pirating the software.
That fucking Dj guy.
So,
Huh?
What's that?
Oh fuck.
I gotta pause.
This niece says we might have a leak somewhere.
Okay.
Ah,
Geez.
Dan.
Not,
not too bad.
Just a little fucking leak.
The J trap downstairs.
Yeah,
never fucking ends.
Um,
anyways,
so Kanye took a screenshot and I guess his dead,
a dead mouse demo five,
however the fuck you say his name.
I'm old.
I should know how to say it.
Um,
I guess he made this software that helps you make an album.
And evidently Kanye allegedly had a website open where you could illegally
download it.
So he called him out.
He goes,
you're not making enough money to pay for this software.
You gotta fucking pirate my shit.
And he would just wrote Dick on it.
So Kanye comes back with a barrage of shit just trashing this DJ talking about
his mouse head.
He got a fan in there.
Mike,
I'm bring my daughter.
She's a big fan of Minnie mouse,
blah,
ba blah,
ba Blah ba blah.
Just like,
just like a corporation,
you know,
just,
just sending reams of paper over,
like on better call.
Saul tried to fucking delay it,
but nowhere in it did.
The man denied that.
He didn't feel that they fucking didn't steal it as far as I could tell,
he just,
he just immediate immediately capitulation just immediately switched it from,
you stole my shit to do with your fucking mouse head,
right?
Yeah.
I actually wanted to fucking jump into the middle of it to give the DJ help
because he kind of was fucking taken the bait.
It was just,
it's like what a chick does.
You know what I mean?
That there is so fucking good at arguing that they fucking,
they spin you off like you got a dead to rights and by the time you come through
the whole thing you're like,
how the fuck did I lose that?
Cause they got,
you never react to that shit.
He should have just laid back,
you know,
on the ropes led Kanye,
punch himself out and then just say yes.
So like I said,
you stole my shit,
you know,
and how's it guy with a mouse had going to take shifts from so many who wore a
leather mini skirt throughout a whole fucking tour.
I mean there was so much shit he could've said back,
but he should,
he should have stayed in the pocket.
I was just like,
I was watching that the way I was watching like a comedian and a Heckler,
you know?
Then it was written.
I was rooting for,
I was rooting for the DJ.
There's room for the DJ in that one provided if the,
if the guy stole,
if we didn't,
either way it was fucking entertaining,
you know.
Nice Twitter battle.
That nice.
Isn't it funny how I'm not in a robots driving cars,
but I like a,
I liked,
I like it.
I like a good Twitter,
Twitter back and forth.
You know,
that's the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning park has
come some music.
Once again.
We always post at the [inaudible] podcast.
A Twitter feed will always tell you what the music is.
Andrew always posted.
I don't know what it is.
I am an old man.
I am just,
I am just now trying to update um,
my music.
Oh my God.
I got to tell you what I was doing the other day.
Holy Shit.
I was listening to,
uh,
I downloaded all this shit,
right?
Alabama shakes.
Fucking love the new one.
That album that they have was to shit the weekend.
I listened to that.
I actually liked that shit.
I got to tell you what was funny though was a ah,
fuck,
I already forgot his name.
Kendrick Lamar.
I'm so fucking old.
Helped me out here guys.
I,
I don't know anything that's going on with any of these people.
Kendrick Lamar,
I'm sitting there,
I have to admit,
I did have this old guy thought and I was embarrassed that I had it.
I was listening to his album and I get to this song and he just keeps going.
This dick ain't fi right.
And I'm just,
and all I could just kept thinking was this won a grammy.
And I'm not saying it didn't deserve it,
but I don't know what the people look like,
who fucking vote for the Grammy's.
But the way people complain about it and now they're always given it to white
people,
right?
Like the Oscars,
I'm imagining it's a bunch of white people,
50s and 60s right.
It takes a while,
I would think to establish yourself enough to even be considered,
you know,
to be on that shit.
And I'm just picturing all these fucking 50 and 60 year old white people just
sitting there listening to these dick ain't free eat right.
And they go like,
you know,
like they can relate to that on some level on I,
yeah.
This is like connects with me.
I'm going to vote with this.
You know,
they probably just drive down the hood and stand there for 20 minutes and count
how many times somebody drives by eight free driving by and they all right.
There's enough people listening to it.
We've got to give it to them.
Um,
so anyways,
but it is the embarrassing thing I was in,
I was I listening to,
I got to make sure I say his name right.
It's Ed.
Is it Sheehan?
Ah,
for fuck sakes.
Belts.
You don't know any I did Conan with this guy.
He was fucking great.
I think he's great.
I just don't fuck it.
She Rand Sharon,
we'll go.
Sharon and I was listening to his album
and I was this,
I was listening to that song.
One,
I was listening to Ed Sheeran,
one in a,
in a Toyota Prius and I was sitting there going,
I am enjoying this.
Like what happened to me?
I used to be I and I used to fucking listen.
I what happened.
Okay.
But when I really look back at the shit that I used to think was bad as some of
it was bad ass stuff,
a lot of it,
you know,
say which people will say about a sensitive fellow like this Ed Eddie here,
right.
You know,
he does dress like a man,
unlike the bands that I listen to in the 80s where they came up just full on.
Not only did they dress like chicks,
they dress like hot chicks trying to hang on.
They,
they,
they were really like the first house,
a real housewives when you look back at a lot of it,
you know what I mean?
Um,
I guess still they were still in their prime in their twenties.
I dunno.
So whatever those are the albums that I was listening to this week.
I literally went from 1970 82,
you know,
I went from like 19,
I don't know,
late sixties to late eighties was what the Fuck I've been listening to for the
last,
I don't know how many friends they worked in a fucking warehouse in the 80s.
And then I immediately went to like 2014,
2015,
2016.
And uh,
I,
I survived.
I somehow survived and I actually enjoy the shit so it,
um,
I dunno,
I dunno if it's going to help me.
I don't know what the point of it is,
but all I know is it's,
it's,
yeah,
that's funny to me.
This deck eight free Lao of,
of the year.
Um,
I'll listen to it more.
I'll try to,
I mean,
it's going into some really white ears here though.
It's probably actually a,
uh,
yeah,
it probably says more about him as an artist if I don't get it,
you know what I mean?
Then if I get it,
he probably doesn't want me to get it.
Like,
I don't want some 48 year old white guy like at my shit.
Um,
oh,
maybe I'm wrong,
but the fuck do I know.
Anyways,
fuck off.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
I shut this off.
Hey,
what's going on is spelt birds the Monday morning podcast on Monday,
June 14th,
2010.
How the hell
are you?
Are you good?
Did you have a good weekend?
Did you,
did you go down to that place with the thing I heard it was nice.
What's it nice?
It is nice.
All that's nice.
My son,
he had a recital this weekend and we were so nervous.
He was all a flustered and more suburban.
Talk about shit that nobody cares about.
Chorus Frank was in the back with the garden hose.
It froze up over the winter,
so we have to buy a new one of those.
So you know,
frank course,
he goes on the Internet and he just starts researching all about those hellos.
Houses.
I can't,
I don't know.
Can you imagine just the is sitting there,
the end of a culdesac like that is your fucking reality.
Rather than having a wine cellar,
I would have just have a secret room of fucking porn with Kleenex for me.
The rub one out or just sit there crying at what?
What became of my life I need,
can you go out and fix his bicycle?
Okay.
No.
Why doesn't he go climb a fucking tree?
Jesus Christ.
What did,
what did they do in the 18 hundreds you wonder why the environment is so fucked
up.
That's it right there buddy.
You just don't want to go out and be a part of your kids' lives.
I don't.
That's why I told you I enjoyed condoms.
I did enjoy condoms.
I just didn't want to bust one in you without one on and now I did and now look
at it.
Look at my face sweetheart.
Can't you see the misery?
Fuck them.
Well,
he half looks like,
Yo,
you go fix this fucking bike.
I'm not yelling.
I'm no,
I'm not
somewhat
tunic and dangle mass.
The forest with the Quran
does capture.
The trick
is to his cohorts to sleep in the tree.
Advice.
Take Shit from anybody.
Question Mark.
Bill sometimes you and your podcast with go fuck yourselves and don't take shit
from anyone.
Well,
let me tell you my story.
Back in November,
a cop pulled me over,
roughed me up,
was a huge asshole and wrote up every rinky dinky ticket he could.
Okay,
now wait a minute.
What happened?
You were just driving down the street and this guy just pulled you over.
I need a little bit of the backstory here.
What's this guy?
Did you know,
did he get into a big fight with his wife and then took it out on you or we did
you say something wise to the guy and he said,
all right,
I'm not in the fucking mood anyways,
let's see if we can figure it out here at the end of the altercation,
I shook his hand,
look him straight in the eyes and gave him that look that says,
I will see you in court asshole.
I showed up in court this Monday to defend myself.
My plan was to stand before that asshole and having him explain his actions to
me in a court of law.
And Dude,
this ain't gonna work out unless she had a witness.
I wanted to ask him.
Even then,
that doesn't work out.
I wanted to ask them if twisting my arm so much that I couldn't use it for a few
days was justified.
I wanted to ask him why he decided that me five six 175 pounds as a threat to
him,
six foot to six foot three 250 that he need to hit me from behind.
Um,
don't call me an Asshole,
but I'm not 100% buy in this story because you didn't say what happened
before this.
This guy just did this.
Is this guy like the fucking worst cop ever?
I don't know.
Here we go.
I wanted to,
I wanted to know why he needed to demean me while I was handcuffed in the back
of the paddy wagon.
I then wanted to ask him how many excessive force complaints he had against him.
The answer is four.
Oh Shit.
So I'm wrong here.
I want him to ask him how his marriage ended.
His ex wife has a restraining order against him for domestic violence.
All right.
I tap out.
You're right.
Sorry.
Uh,
I wanted to ask him what part of protect and serve did he not understand?
I want it to end the questioning with him explaining how he got caught on a cell
phone camera.
Assaulting a motorist.
You can look up the video on youtube under Milwaukee Police Lambo,
driver l a m B o driver.
Here's what sucks in Milwaukee.
If the cop that wrote you the ticket doesn't show up in court,
your case is dismissed and you don't have to pay anything.
We'll guess.
Guess why I told you that the piece of shit didn't show up in court.
Oh,
that's awful.
I need advice too.
I let this
all be water under the bridge or do I take this fucker down?
I really want justice,
but I don't want to be beaten by other cops.
What should I do?
Um,
well I think you just shed some light.
Milwaukee police,
lambo driver.
All my listeners will probably look up and watch that.
Um,
now this guy sounds like a dangerous guy.
Look,
you know,
this is,
listen,
what I would do if I was going to try to take this dude down,
what I would do is,
you know what the local news loves doing now.
They love showing like youtube videos and they love talking about Twitter and
all that type of stuff because they're desperately trying to get the kids and
people because they're losing all this viewership to,
uh,
to the Internet.
So the fact
that you,
you have this controversial thing,
you have this fucked up law and you have a youtube video of this guy,
um,
that makes,
that's like one of those perfect little pieces,
you know,
coming up next Milwaukee police officer or a little out of line,
check out the youtube video that everybody's been talking about all the Lord at.
Yeah.
I mean,
you could go that way.
Uh,
but yeah,
I mean you're,
you're taking a,
you're definitely going to take a fucking risk.
MMM.
You know,
so you can know Rodney King died this week and that brought up that whole video
and all that type of shit.
And I know,
you know,
the guy just pulled over.
That's what you supposed to do.
I know.
I mean,
they look who's kitten know Rodney King was going to get beat down no matter
what.
I mean,
if you've run from the fucking cops,
I don't give a fuck who you are.
You've got to get beat down.
But if you get back up,
you charge him a couple of times.
Abso-Fucking-Lutely but you know,
there's gotta be a way to take a guy down without giving them 12 fucking skull
fractures.
You know what I'm saying?
It's,
I dunno,
it's,
it's
okay.
It's a fucking thankless job and then it's a really dangerous job.
If,
if the wrong kind of person gets a,
gets the job,
why did my phone just go off?
Oh,
that's right.
I gotta do that ship.
So,
um,
I don't know.
Personally,
I can't,
I can't eat ever watch that Rodney king thing again.
That's like fucking its most brutal thing ever.
And actually when you watch that,
now you go,
thank God they got fucking a,
what do you call those things?
Taser.
What did,
what did we clear?
What do you call those things?
What do they call those things?
They just,
uh,
these Zappia.
Did you guys ever see that one?
Um,
that one where they,
the cop.
What the fuck do you call those things?
He got tased.
He got fucking,
is it a taser?
Cleo?
Why am I so dumb?
Ah,
fucking love this dog.
You know that Cleo,
um,
underrated having a dog.
It's the best fucking thing ever.
Anyways,
I got,
I got to get you this youtube video now that it brought it up.
It's a,
okay.
It's basically they're doing a demonstration of one of those fucking things.
Whatever the fuck you call him that I just can't think,
why do I keep saying it's a taser?
I know.
It's not a he is it a taser?
He got tazed I can't fuck it.
My brain is mush.
So anyways,
there's one cop gonna Zap another cop to,
uh,
the demonstrate it to the class and look,
man,
I don't give a fuck how much of a man you are.
You get fucking Zappo electricity.
You're gonna make a noise.
Most guys go like are on,
they fucking go down to,
uh,
this guy fucking shoots it at the guy.
And this dude sounds like he's like ending an opera.
He gets tased.
He's like
just fucking drunk.
He does literally
something like that and drops.
And I just love how the cop was,
shoots them,
tries to act like he just didn't scream out like a little fucking girl,
man.
It's hilarious.
But,
um,
but getting back to that,
yeah,
dude,
that's,
that's a serious,
yeah,
that's a serious thing.
And you and you,
you know,
if this guy really is as bad as you're saying,
the right thing is not to let it go.
The right thing is to try and shed some light on it and hopefully that they can
get this guy off the force because he's given decent cops a bad name.
There you go.
So,
but your,
your worries are definitely a,
you know,
valid.
Yeah.
I mean,
considering none of those cops during the Rodney King,
none of them got fucking,
they got,
they got off.
If you can get off doing that.
I mean,
Jesus Christ,
you know,
that dude who shot that kid on that platform and in Oakland,
that was fucking brutal.
He's like,
oh,
I thought it was my,
uh,
daughter was my house keys.
I didn't realize it was my gun and he fucking got away with that.
I'm not trashing cops,
I'm just saying,
not saying they're all fucking bad,
but I'm just saying it's,
it's,
it's practically fucking impossible.
MMM.
It literally,
even if you have video,
I think you have to have the combination of having video and then you have to be
okay.
You have to be a certain level of a wealth and influence.
Okay.
Because if you're broke,
you know,
I don't think that they're,
that you know,
you,
there's no way they're just going to be like,
yeah,
go fuck yourself.
You'd done,
you know,
and then when you add racism into it,
I mean,
you're pretty much,
it's pretty much game set match,
which is fucking unfortunate.
So,
um,
I don't know.
I'm talking about society way beyond my fucking right.
The lexo.
I'm going to tap out here already trashed fucking hair metal.
Now I would have fucking angry a psycho cops.
[inaudible]
um,
all right.
Lights,
camera dumped bill.
I'm a 29 year old guy and recently broke up with a funny,
attractive and all around.
Great girl.
Oh Gee.
Why Sir would you do that?
You ask.
All right.
MMM.
Two things.
Her Dad was born without teeth and your words,
your baby will if you breed with her or
she has got something going on in the vaginal area,
some sort of odor,
stinky pussy.
I don't know.
Well,
here we go.
let me tell you,
this girl and I had been dating for about three months and we had a great thing
going.
She's half Afro Cuban,
half Puerto Rican and really sexy.
She had a rough upbringing,
but I didn't care because she's honest,
easygoing and not bitchy.
Like so many girls I dated,
she was a bit needy,
but I didn't mind.
Okay.
Um,
we were out at a bar one night having a few drinks and I was feeling pretty
good.
I was looking at a couple of floozies at the end of the bar and asked her if
she's ever been with another woman.
She coyly looked at me and said,
yes.
Okay,
good stuff.
I thought,
yeah,
dude,
this is a fucking fantasy right here.
Fucking red shoe diaries.
Um,
then I proceeded with,
have you ever been in a threesome with two girls and a guy again?
She answered yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
Kind of slutty,
but I'm no saint.
While I couldn't stop.
They are God.
You're going to go for the rotisserie question.
What's in the box?
Ah,
here we go.
Here we go.
Strap yourselves in for this one.
Well,
I couldn't stop there.
So I asked,
have you ever had a threesome with two guys?
She looked down at the ground and she looked up a bit ashamed,
Lee and said yes.
Wow.
SCAG alert.
I thought I then asked her one more question.
I knew this one could back.
Where the fuck do you go from here?
Yeah,
like throwing the high heat to Albert Albert Pool House.
I finally asked,
wait,
have you ever been in a porn?
Okay.
She then blushed and look me in the eye and said,
yeah,
okay.
I looked at her calmly and was like,
oh,
but inside I was like,
Jesus fucking Christ.
Yes.
Well you should.
Okay.
You know those first couple,
I mean,
you can look at,
let's,
let's break this down here.
All right.
She's been with,
uh,
she's had a threesome with another girl and a guy who gets that.
That's who gives a fuck right there.
All right.
You're already knew she banged another guy.
But,
uh,
the fact that she also did it with another girl,
that takes a little fucking,
uh,
that tones down his dick in her pussy.
Right.
This is how guys think.
Women,
I'm sorry.
All right.
That's something that,
that's something in the,
yeah,
the credit.
Is it the credit a bit.
Why?
Why,
why do you try to talk up counting shit you to dump.
All right.
That was all right.
The two guys thing.
Now you can look the other way on that.
Maybe if it,
if it was in another state,
but it can't be in the same state because if you run into one of the two guys
that fucking,
you know,
we're high fiving is they fucking bagged her that.
I mean I I know about that one.
But then the third one she did a porno.
I mean,
yeah,
no that's a,
you've got to walk away from that
or,
or you have to go to NASA to get tested for the latest fucking STDs I would
think.
And then also God knows what's going on,
uh,
mentally that you would do that.
What?
I just like sex now.
Non Health is something going on.
Who doesn't like sex?
I Dunno.
Anyways,
plowing ahead.
See she's so,
she egos.
So basically she had moved down to Los Angeles when she was 20.
She's now 25 and after a short stint in the military,
some hours she got into the porn industry for eight months.
She did everything.
Ooh,
fuck.
Shocked.
The whole Shebang.
I asked her if I could see her video,
but she wouldn't tell me her performer name.
It said Vietnam,
the that it would be impossible to find her body of work.
I asked her why she got into porn and she replies,
cause I wanted some feeling in my life and then he rides dao.
Ji Ji is,
yeah,
dude.
Oh this poor girl.
Something happened to her.
The thing was she was clean,
had a good job and I really liked her and the sex was great.
Yeah,
obviously,
you know,
it's funny,
there was something you wrote in the beginning where I just thought she was
going to be good.
29 year old guy.
Attractive all around.
Great girl.
Oh,
the fact that you said she had a rough brain upbringing,
but she was easy going and honest and not bitchy right there.
I was like,
that girl's good in bed.
That just seemed like a kind of free open person.
I don't know.
I didn't know she was going to be that open owed EEG.
Um,
anyways,
the thing was,
she was clean and I have a blog.
The sex is great,
but I couldn't stop picturing her in some sleazy porno that was probably filmed
in some junk yard on labrea.
So I went to ask for friend's advice.
Most of my guys were telling me to dumper my gay friends told me it was fabulous
and then I should overlook it.
I didn't even bother asking my girlfriends because they would automatically
reject her and assume I had aids.
There you go,
keep your options open.
So regretfully I dumped her,
I felt terrible and obviously didn't tell her it was because she was a porn star
because she would have been ashamed for the rest of her life and I was happy
that she was honest with me.
I've done my fair share of sleeves,
but this was too much.
My question bill was,
Bill,
my question bill,
was it wrong for me to dump her for some decisions she made years ago?
Should I have stayed with her?
What would have you done?
Um,
well you don't want to know what I would've done.
I'm a fucking degenerate.
So lets you,
you seem like a good person
dude.
When you're trying to find the person you're going to spend the rest of your
life with you,
you have to have a list of criteria.
All right.
Sound like you're still young.
So there's no reason to compromise.
Yeah.
All right.
I mean when you get with somebody like that and you're going to live with them
and you wouldn't get with anybody,
you're taking on all of their fucking baggage.
Yeah.
All right.
You're only three months in
and you know people who go into the porn industry that,
you know,
it's like people would come,
comedians were not healthy individuals.
Okay.
And that is like a specific area that I just,
this is just my own personal nonmedical feeling that you're just not a healthy
person.
Something awful happen.
And that line,
I just wanted to feel something.
I mean,
something bad happened to her,
caused her to Waller self off.
I don't even want to try to guess what,
but you know,
okay,
there's nothing wrong with anything that she did purse.
You don't technically,
and she was honest with it.
It all comes down to whether or not you want to deal with it all right.
And if you feel that you know,
you want to deal with it and that there was this sort of connection that you
just had,
this girl had to be in your life,
then you're going to have to learn to live with it.
Okay.
And get past it.
MMM.
But I would be definitely,
I would definitely be concerned with a certain mental issues,
um,
now like she's insane.
And then I would also be concerned with,
uh,
okay.
Sexual boundaries.
Okay.
You know?
Like would she have any and could she remain faithful after a while and when you
settle into the seven year itch or whatever,
yeah.
And you really start needing to work at the relationship and it's feeling boring
and she needs to feel something again.
Is she going to go back to that?
Okay.
Leather couch from that show,
Martin,
my end,
you know,
down on fog in the valley and get bagged again.
I mean,
I don't know.
I Dunno.
That is a,
uh,
that is,
you know what,
that is beyond my skills.
I don't know how to tame that horse.
I can tell you that.
Right fucking enough.
I,
I have no fucking clue.
That's a,
a,
you know what,
that's a doctor drew question.
Okay.
That is a classic doctor drew question.
And that guy within two seconds we'll get right to the core of it.
I would call out,
call in love line,
man.
If you're out here,
call him up.
Cause that's a,
that's a great one.
Um,
yeah,
I guess you'd have to figure out is,
is,
has she works through whatever the fuck she was working through and now she's
ready to.
Okay.
I mean,
I dunno.
Day,
those are some good looking girls down there and she's like,
yeah they are or whatever.
Like,
I mean if you kept steering it in that direction,
you'd probably get you fucking threesome right there.
Um,
so there's that,
there's that option.
The option that you have is if you're with her,
like I think he can me that.
That's,
that's a selfish fucking and I,
and a shallow reason to stay with somebody long term.
Uh,
yeah.
Geez.
I don't know.
Ah,
it's to police in the corners gun and
shoot.
Just said,
please don't control the sliders.
Can Be Nice to say.
Further smile.
Um,
all right,
beef Kurt and advice for those of you in the states,
that's a slang for the Hoo Ha beef curtains.
Do the math.
Think about it.
All right,
you ready?
Okay.
Here we go.
Here's the situation.
I have a wonderful girl in my life.
Uh,
what and when she doesn't know how to fuck.
That's what I'm guessing.
I'm guessing this is where it's going.
I wonderful growing my life.
Great attitude,
humor,
big tits,
nice ass and a good family.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
marry this girl.
Sure.
It seems good for now,
but I have one issue.
She also has some mean beef curtains.
Then he put in front sees pussy lips just in case.
I didn't know.
Uh,
that kind of bug me bug the ever living shit out of me whenever we get down to
the dirty business.
So much.
So to the point I looked up some cosmetic surgery that basically gives the beef
curtains a trim job and beauties the vagina.
Wow,
dude.
Wow.
All right.
Now before I read the rest of this,
if you're going to fucking ask me how to have this conversation,
like listen,
love,
I love you,
I love your family.
I love you.
You're hot,
everything.
But is there any way you can trim your beef curtains?
Maybe you can get away with it cause you got that cool accent.
I don't know.
But she has it too,
so she's not going to give a fuck.
He may pull this off with some foreign chick anyways.
Um,
so he looks up cosmetic surgery to try on a beautify the vagina.
Now I know by now I must sound like a douchebag focusing on the little things.
No,
because women do that to women.
Focus on little things like that.
That's a serious dude.
Sex is a big fucking thing.
But anyways,
he says,
well,
my thinking is I'm truly going to pull the trigger.
He spelled it that way and keep this woman all the myself for the rest of my
life.
Aren't I entitled to have a great looking VAD to look at it for as long as our
bodies don't wrinkle away.
Wow.
I know there's a lot of women are fucking annoyed by this one.
Yeah.
What about you fucking Dick and your wrinkled balls
once you get a face lift for you sack there buddy.
I know they're all saying that.
Um,
how can I ever bring this option up to her without,
I knew he's going to ask me without completely destroying her feelings or making
her hate me for being so pussy conscious.
Thanks for the read.
Now go fuck yourself.
All right.
This is a simple one,
dude.
There is no fucking way
you can bring that up to her without absolutely completely destroying her
feelings.
So you either need to accept this or you have to view off the letter.
Go.
That's it.
I mean,
I would think that if you actually truly cared about this girl,
now all the chicks are going to be like,
oh,
I knew he had a heart underneath all those c words.
Um,
if you truly care about this girl,
uh,
I would think that that wouldn't matter.
You know,
and if she looks the way she,
she's saying you're saying that she looks,
I mean what,
what are we talking here?
Like how far down when these things hanging as it like you know it's,
I mean if she got them,
both of them peers,
could you like do like uh,
could you like as bad as they could you be like,
do you like that Olympic?
The fuck is that thing here.
You're on the rings.
Could you do that and still swing your feet up and not hit her pussy and we're
talking like it's that bad.
You know,
if you did the iron cross would your head be in her pussy?
Like how far these things hanging down?
Hey now
what's the deal with big gardens?
All right dude,
there's no way
there's,
there's no fucking way.
And don't,
don't do that to her because she can't do anything about that.
If she had a problem with her fucking vaginal area,
you would have known by now because she would have been self conscious and she
would have brought it up the way.
Sometimes girls do about parts of their bodies and they are super self conscious
about their bodies because we're so fucking visual.
All right.
I told you one time when the first girls I ever hooked up with,
when I got her shirt off and her bra off,
she rolled her eyes and I thought she was thinking that I,
I was like,
oh my God.
Like I'm not doing it for like she's rolling her eyes.
Like this guy's lame.
And I found out later she was self conscious about the size of her breasts.
So I totally took it the wrong fucking way.
I made it all about me because I'm self involved.
So dot.
Yeah,
don't do that to her.
All right.
Either you can that that's when you just suddenly have in your head.
Either you accept that shit or you move on,
but there's no reason to hurt this person because you're a shallow cut like me.
All right.
Cheers.
[inaudible].